robson you think you're some kind of
origami ninja star assassin master now
you don't even make it right I have
double sided ninja star and mini double
sided ninja star what you going to do
throw your paper water bomb at me ha ha
ha
first of all your bangs are out of
control and second of all I have a super
shuriken made of six single sided ninja
stars interlocked together to make the
ultimate fighting weapon the single and
the double sided ninja stars both are
really cool easy and fun to make the
double-sided ones look a little bit
nicer since they are the same on both
sides and I'm going to show you how to
make these today you're going to need
two full-sized sheets of printer paper
just like these if you have the white
one that's fine I'm going to be using
some colored paper that I found in
Staples just to put a little bit of
color into the ninja star I also have a
tutorial for how to make a single sided
ninja star that you can find by clicking
on this link up here and one thing
that's cool about those is the fact that
you can connect them to make this giant
super shuriken or ninja star frisbee I'm
not going to show you how to do that in
this tutorial but if you would like to
see a short how-to on how to do that
leave me a comment below and I'll see
you about making a video on that so once
you have your two pieces of
regular-sized printer paper you're ready
to begin we need to have two pieces of
square paper so what we do with both of
these printer sheets is we take this
corner and we fold it across until this
edge on the top is aligned with the side
edge make creases and then we can cut
off or tear off the excess paper when
you do so you'll have two pieces of
paper that look like this and if you
open them you'll notice they are square
what you want to do is before you open
it set one up like this on the right and
set one up like this on the left so that
when you open them you'll see that the
diagonal folds one is going this way and
one is going that way now what we're
going to do is we're going to fold both
of these papers in half by taking the
top end
and folding it down to the bottom end
make a crease and then we want to take
the top of this paper again and fold it
down in half to the bottom end and make
another crease do the same with the
right sheet fold it down and make crease
and then fold it down once more so you
should have one piece of paper on the
left that looks like this and one piece
of paper on the right that looks like
that now we're going to take both of the
pieces and you want to take the end of
the paper and fold it across in half to
the other end make sure its edge to edge
and just make a crease down the end so
I'll draw a line there to show you
exactly where the fold occurred do the
same with this one pull it across in
half
okay so you should have two pieces of
paper that looked just like that
and if you set it up just like I did
when I showed you to put the angles of
the paper like that like a triangle you
should notice that you have these other
lines here too so let me mark them as
well it's not a big deal if you don't
have those you can just follow along
while I go through the folds but that
will let you know where you need to make
the fold on each of the sheets there's
going to be a fold that occurs right on
that line and as you'll notice the
pieces are mirror images they are not
the same like in my single sided ninja
star tutorial alright so let's go ahead
and make those folds as well so whatever
you do to the left one you're going to
do the opposite to the right one so
let's start with the left side we're
going to fold the left side of this
piece up onto that midline so you want
to take the left left side and you're
going to make it so that this edge here
is aligned with that vertical edge just
like that and then you make a crease so
as you'll notice we folded along that
line that we had there now for the piece
on the right the left side is going to
go down it's going to be the opposite so
we're going to fold the left side down
on that line and then make another
crease now the right side of the piece
is going to go down here
and the right side of this piece is
going to go up along that line that we
had there so as you'll notice these two
pieces are mirror images left side of
this one is up right sides down left
side of this one is down and right side
is up so once you have two pieces that
look just like that you're ready to move
on we need to flip the models over
completely but before we do I want you
to take a quick look again if you set it
up like I did in the beginning you
should see a crease on the left going
diagonally this way and a crease on the
right piece going diagonally this way
that's going to let you know where we
need to make the next fold but if you
don't see those creases it's not a big
deal I'm going to show you how to fold
the pieces exactly so what we need to do
is just flip the pieces over like that
and we're going to be making two pieces
I like to call one the Z piece and one
the S piece they're going to come out
like this and as you'll see this one
looks like a Z and this piece looks like
an S so they are mirror images of each
other and they're going to fit together
so what we need to do we're going to
take this corner here in the upper right
of the left piece and we're going to
fold it down to this corner and as
you'll notice that is along that crease
that is previously there so the left
piece take the upper right corner fold
it down to the lower left and we make a
crease and then on this piece we're
going to take the upper left corner and
fold it down to the lower right again
that is along that crease there
okay and for the bottom here we're going
to take the lower left and fold it this
way it should be in the direction of
these lines here take the corner and
fold it in that direction you should not
be taking this corner and folding it
like this and winding up with something
that looks like that it needs to look
like a Z so this corner is going to be
folded in words just like that to that
corner make another crease and we're
going to take this corner and fold it in
this way so you should have the Z piece
and the S piece that look just like that
and you're ready to fit them together
and finish your ninja star you are ready
to complete your double sided origami
ninja star oh shriek it all we need to
do is to fold the flaps in words and to
interlock the two pieces together to
finish our ninja star it might be a
little tricky at first to get the pieces
together but you'll see it's really
simple once you get the hang of it I'm
going to go through in as much detail as
I can in this step so I need you guys to
pay really close attention as I go
through it so to fold the flaps inwards
we just need to take this flap and fold
it down and take this flap and fold it
up make a crease along the top and the
bottom and do the same for the piece on
the right fold this piece down and fold
this piece up and make a crease it's
okay if the flaps reopen like that we
kind of want it like that in order to
interlock the two pieces which I have
labeled Z and s we need to make one of
the pieces the bottom and one of the
pieces the top it doesn't really matter
but I like to choose the Z piece as my
bottom and the S piece is there for the
top to join them we need to make sure
that the flaps are facing each other
right now both of the flaps on the
pieces are facing towards us so we can't
just put this piece on top of it and
join it we need to flip one of the
pieces over since the Z piece is going
to be the bottom we're going to flip the
S piece over just like that as you'll
see the flaps are now facing away from
us and we have this line here horizontal
if you flipped it and you
the piece like this you'll see you can't
join it to the to the Z piece like that
because they line up so when you flip it
just make sure that that line is
horizontal and then you could lay the
piece on top of the Z piece so again the
S piece is flipped over and made sure
that this line is horizontal and placed
on top of the Z piece and you should see
the two pieces form what looks like an X
in the middle so we need to interlock
the bottom piece flaps into the top
piece as you'll see if you lay the flaps
down you'll see where they need to go
this flap needs to be put underneath
here so what you do is you just lift
this up and you place that flap
underneath there this piece needs to go
underneath here so just lift it up and
we could tuck this one underneath there
so you should have a piece that looks
just like that and just make really good
creases and make sure everything is nice
and flat then we could flip the model
over and as you'll see we have two
pockets here we have one pocket here and
we have another pocket here this piece
is going to fit into this pocket and
this piece on the left is going to fit
into the pocket on the right so all we
need to do is just tuck the tip of the
flap into the opposite pocket tuck the
left flap into the right pocket you
might need to open this up a little with
a pen cap or something tuck it in there
and then you could tuck the right flap
into the left pocket so just open this
up a little bit and you should be able
to tuck that right in just like that
make sure everything is flat and you
have finished your origami ninja star to
throw this shuriken just fling it like a
frisbee at this angle